(crépitement des flammes)
- Des brasiers gourmands
dans l'Ouest canadien...
des communautés balafr
par Fiona dans l'est du pays,
sans compter toutes
les catastrophes naturelles
dans le monde qui resteront
dans les annales de 2022.
Des événements marquants,
potentiellement exacerbées
par les effets des changements
climatiques, mais qui n'ont
visiblement pas su convaincre
les 193 États à s'engager
à la hauteur de la crise,
seununun nouveau rapport
de l'ONU.
EDDY PÉREZ, Réseau action climat
- On a quand même vu un léger
progrès par rapport à...
à ce qu'on avait l'année passée.
Donc, il y a eu quand même
un changement de 3 %,
mais ce n'est pas ça
que la science exige
- Le rapport de l'ONU indique
que les engagements actuels
des paysononont augmenter
les émissions de 10,6 %
d'ici 2030 par rapport
auveveveaux de 2010.
Alors qu'on devrait plutôt
les réduire de plus de 40 %
d'ici 2030 afin de limiter
r r réchauffement climatique
à 1,5 degré Celcius.
- Pourtant, au terme
de la COP26 à Glasgow,
les pays s'étaient engagés
à rehausser leuibibibles
climatiques avant la COP27
en Égypte.
Le Canada fait partie de ceux
qui n'ons s s respecté leurs
promesses.
- Le Canada a échoué le premier
test avant que la COP27
commence. Le premier test était
de présenter un plan climat
renforcé comme le Canada s'était
engagé à le faire à Glasgow.
- Il y a un an, les données
montraient que les émissions
projetées continueraient
d'augmenter au-delà de 2030.
Si les nouvelles données
démontrent que les émissions
n'augmentent plus après 2030,
elles n'affichent toujours pas
une tendance à la baisse rapide
que la science juge nécessaire.
Le Canada, lui, s'est doté
d'un plan climatique incluant
un cadre législatif. Or, selon
les experts, le pays ne se donne
pas les moyens de ses ambitions
et se garde bien de fournir
des échéanciers. De plus, Ottawa
manquerait de transparence.
- On ne sait pas, par exemple,
comment la limitation des
émissions du secteur pétrolier
et gazier, comment est-ce que
ça va contribuer, par exemple,
à aider le gouvernement
du Canada à atteindre
les objectifs du pays.
- Les rapports accablants
s'accumulent sans qu'on sache
vraiment quels sont les plans
concrets pour atteindre
les cibles promises, alors
que 2030 est à nos portes
et que les phénomènes
climatiques nous rappellent
de plus en plus souvent
ce laisser-aller.